Steve has a good question here do you
think Aristotle would still consider
someone virtuous if they're in the mean
most of the time does he make allowances
for human imperfection absolutely
um the The Virtuous person behaves we
could say to use a modern term reliably
in the way a virtuous person does
they may sometimes have lapses
they shouldn't be the sort of lapses
where you're like holy crap this is
really out of character for this person
you know like uh in terms of anger right
uh if they're usually getting angry at
people for the right time for the right
amount they're being forgiving and stuff
like that and then they get into like a
battle on Twitter with somebody and then
you find out that they like went to this
person's house and knocked on the door
and the person opened the door and they
punched him in the face and then started
kicking them you'd be like whoa that's
uh that's definitely not you know
virtuous anger what's going on here
maybe this person didn't really have the
virtue but if it's minor lapses
Aristotle is going to be okay with that
it's the general tendency of the
person's actions and it's the
motivational structure right
you can be reliably doing virtuous
action but if you if you don't take
pleasure in it if it causes you pain to
do it you're not really virtuous you're
just kind of like going through the
motions maybe to try to become virtuous
or maybe to stay out of trouble or maybe
to get a promotion at work or to impress
your date or something like that right
so yeah there's there's a lot of there's
there's wiggle room in here you could
say
um Nicole says what about individuals
who have people pleasing behaviors a
hard time saying no they're virtue they
appear virtuous but based on what you're
saying they're not yeah
this is that's exactly it being a people
pleaser is not being virtuous being a
people pleaser is just doing
um what you're being told to do or you
know following social norms that you've
internalized
and it's not for the right reason it's
just to like um avoid anxiety or
discomfort or to try to get in good with
other people it's not for the sake of
the noble
um and that's I think something that's a
good point and that's something that we
just kind of have to accept that people
pleasing is not by itself virtuous
Behavior
so
okay so Bruce has an interesting
question how does this virtue so
generosity and
um magnificence how do they relate to
the state
um you could say the generosity by
itself
doesn't really it's it's on an ordinary
scale but magnificence does
um and so to Jump Ahead a little bit
the ancient Greeks as I think is the
case in many communities including those
that we live in today although it's a
little bit different today and important
respects they thought that if you had
significant resources if you were Rich
we'll just say right then
um you shouldn't just keep your money to
yourself you shouldn't just say well you
know trickle down economics everybody or
something like that you should be making
direct contributions that make your
community better and I mean not
everything under magnificence
necessarily fits into that you know
House Furnishing okay unless you're
having big parties and inviting
everybody over that's not benefiting the
community as a whole
but
um
you know
he uses the example of equipping a try
ream that's your Navy right so that is
pretty important from the perspective of
the state you're helping to arm the
um the State against its its enemies and
you probably have enemies right uh in
any given case or
um doing a public banquet I mean now
that's not necessarily like a political
action but it could figure into that so
Bruce asks would this virtue be apparent
in an agrarian Community or
hunter-gatherer group in other words
does this virtue have a necessity I mean
in a way it sort of like um does it
belong to all humans as such or do you
have to reach a certain level of Social
Development we might and
I mean Aristotle doesn't talk about that
I mean he I think he is assuming we're
talking about people living in a subtle
political Community but why why wouldn't
it apply to Nomads or hunter-gatherers
or herds people I mean he does discuss
these ways of life in
um
the politics book one
um he actually calls Nomads or he calls
a herders people who are living on a
mobile farm right
um and so I think he sees the the
connections there
um you could even say like a criminal
group or or groups that he also talks
about like you know uh he calls uh man
Stealers you know people who would like
kidnap people and sell them as slaves
within that Community you could still
have generosity being
um shown by its members towards each
other couldn't you so I think that it is
a necessity in that it is
um a possibility for human beings
in almost any sort of situation I mean
let's take a limit case the island of
the Cyclops is in the Odyssey where each
person is each Cyclops is totally on
their own and it's a very male dominated
thing because it says that you know they
dominate their wives and children and
herds and then they have no relations to
anyone else
um Aristotle would say okay they're not
going to be generous they they are bad
by not being generous and being stingy
but they don't really have much of a
chance for it but the rest of us
we have lots and lots of opportunities
for generosity don't we so any other
questions uh before we jump into looking
at the virtuous mean
uh for this
so Todd what would be an example of
right taking from Aristotle's time
there's a lot of wrong taking examples
but the only right taking he mentioned
seems to be taking from one's own wealth
so how does this fit in with getting
paid for work
um I don't think I mean he doesn't
mention it but I don't think he'd have a
problem with getting paid for work
um you know you could more easily take
from your own resources if you had a
household right because along with a
household goes household manufacturing
he's got an entire book that may or may
not be by Aristotle called the economics
which means household management and
then you know
um it's going to be harder to be
um you know fully generous if you're
what he calls a bosane a manual worker
this is probably one of those places
where we want to say yeah Aristotle's uh
probably misled by his own culture you
know
um the the key is to avoid I would say
professions where you're doing ignoble
things or taking advantage of people you
know
like here's here's a prime example from
ancient times something that Aristotle
didn't talk about but
two stoic skolarcs actually disagreed
about is a thought experiment you have a
ship and you're pulling into a port
where there's a famine going on
you have a ship that's completely loaded
up with grain right and you could sell
it at like famine prices and you know
that the next day there's another ship
coming in also loaded up with grain and
you know people will have enough to to
live on do you take advantage of that
and not tell anybody that hey help more
help is on the way and make a huge
profit off of it
or do you have a duty to reveal the
truth about that and um diogenes of
Babylon said nah you don't have to tell
the truth about that uh and then Auntie
Potter said oh diogenes that's terrible
of course you do right and we could get
into all sorts of situations like that I
I think if you're if you're doing
anything
that's
um socially productive and you're not
like over charging I think Aristotle
probably wouldn't have too much of a
problem with that but it's it's it's an
important um
consideration I think you could say
um this is you know we're trying to
adapt things from a different culture
Aristotle is probably not from the same
social class as all of us so maybe he's
got some blinders on
so Allison has a good good
um uh Point here it seems that wealth is
probably more Central now than ever a
lot of young people this is a very very
good point appear to be very anxious
about having beans to survive I would
say that that jobs with my experience
too and I'm I'm going to say something
by way of digression
and it's not necessarily going to apply
globally but I think it does apply here
in the United States and and perhaps to
our you know our neighbor to the north
Canada as well and whether the supplies
in other places
um others would have to weigh in so you
know I'm from what's called Generation X
and my parents generation were the Baby
Boomers and the Baby Boomers were part
of this you know climb in the they were
born in you know uh from the 40s onward
in the 50s and 60s after World War II
America was doing quite well I mean we
still had some massive massive problems
with racism and sexism and stuff like
that and environmental degradation
um but you could say that on the whole
you know that that expression
um Rising you know Rising what is it a
rising tide raises all boats that's part
of what was going on College was very
affordable and was a fairly guaranteed
way to raise your social status you
could have a blue-collar job and bring
home enough money to provide you know a
decent existence for your family and you
probably would have a pension as well
and there were there were lots of other
things
um you could you could afford to buy a
house fairly cheaply right in that
generation already in my generation
student loans were becoming much more
difficult in in many respects you you
had to prepayment penalties interest
rates were higher you couldn't get out
of them they started passing legislation
in favor of the loan Industries housing
started to become much more expensive
and the implied social contract of go to
college and you're gonna you know get a
job that started to break down
for the Next Generation the Millennials
who are now long out of college
um it got even worse in those respects
and for the current generation that's
you know uh teenagers and and
20-somethings the Generation z
um things are pretty bad you know
the covid
um crisis revealed many cracks within
our our system and I think there's a
kind of sense among the younger people
that whatever social contract there was
whatever American dream was motivating
us that was for previous generations and
not for them and again I leave that to
others to decide whether that applies to
their country or not Nicole
um David says would you say our
individualistic culture along with our
Doom and Gloom news media tips the scale
in favor of practicality over generosity
um
I would say it does so if you let it I
mean I don't think that you have to it's
not like an automatic you just push the
buttons and the human beings respond
like robots
um
you know
and calling it practicality over
generosity I think is already an
interesting choice of of language you
know
it's it I think there is a legitimate
um desire there for Financial Security
on the part of all of us but it doesn't
have to lead us into being stingy
um I mean there will be many cases where
like you just don't have anything to
give monetarily I mean you could still
volunteer time or something like that
but you know if you're trying to pay
down debts and living on beans and rice
and you know not going out anywhere and
then you get some somebody coming to the
door and you're like
every every dollar has been budgeted man
um I I don't think that that would be
being ungenerous
Nicole says there's a beautiful castle
home in my neighborhood the man
decorated beautifully it is now a free
museum for public enjoyment did this
turn into magnificence or was it way
back when he bought the furniture the
answer is both
um Aristotle would say so we're going to
talk about this a little bit more when
we get to it that how you furnish your
home is
um that's a matter of magnificence and
that's kind of interesting right because
you don't have to be like super rich to
have a home
um so we'll talk about that turning it
into something for the public like
there's actually a home here in
Milwaukee that we've been to pre-covid
and it's been turned into a museum it's
only you know like maybe 10 blocks from
here and it's it's like a mansion and
it's gigantic and it's beautiful
and it's filled with works of art and
they had like a they had a uh a talk
there and then we got to visit the
artwork and I would say yeah that that
is a matter of magnificence and it can
be done well and it can be done poorly
so
and Nicole has a great question here
what about lavish birthday parties yeah
I think that that fits the occasion like
for dogs
so dogs don't care about their birthday
that's a human thing you know and
inviting everybody over with their dogs
and having party favors and a cake and
stuff like that that's kind of silly now
that said I I will mention that
um people do this sort of thing and I
know this in part because my wife used
to make gourmet dog cookies that she was
surprised people would pay so much money
for Allison says in my country during
our economic boom of the early Arts it
was children's parties limos thank God
thank goodness no dog ones yet yeah when
there's lots of money floating around
this is a good point when there's lots
of money floating around people who
don't have a good sense of
um magnificence often become vulgar
because they're like let's let's blow
money on this sort of thing you know
let's let's spend on this you know
all right so here's a good uh question
from Malcolm does he mean what can be
measured in money in a practical sense
or an A normative sense both
um because he doesn't make that
distinction
he's just telling us that if it can be
measured by money if it's value it can
be measured by money then it falls
within the scope of this this virtue and
yeah almost anything can be valued in
money and it's interesting because
um
there is more and more things that in
previous generations we might have been
quite leery except in certain
circumstances of trying to value in
terms of money and you could say that
um this is one of the the functions of
capitalism which is you know gone
through many many Transformations as a
whole but it penetrates into areas and
it brings money relations and money
value and then you know the sort of
instrumentalization of things into areas
that were originally
viewed as off limits
like you know think about this how much
would you be willing to pay
for you know an opportunity for your kid
you could think about this in terms of
like bribing school officials to let
your kids into an elite Institution
well we know that there is a monetary
value to that because we have these
School scandals and people do it now is
it consistent no I mean it's going to
vary from person to person but yeah I
mean
almost anything can be given a sign some
sort of monetary value Bruce
so George that you mentioned money is
there to be circulated what do you mean
by that exactly what I said circulating
means that you you spend it and it goes
around right
um and the person who has the money then
can use the money for something else
this is this is a a point that's
um very important for local communities
I'll tell you about an example of that
in a sec but first let me
um
read the rest money is there to be
useful to others in terms of value such
as business property taxes when is it
correct to say money is not being
circulated property in an individual
sense versus a sociological sense
um there is no like verses there
um individuals are parts of groups
um or societies and and you know money
is by itself already relational it
doesn't have any value if you hoard it
up and never spend it on anything you
know it has its value in how it's used
to facilitate interactions and
transactions and and Aristotle actually
in the politics is going to make a
distinction between
[Music]
um
um what he calls natural wealth and it
doesn't mean like it's coming directly
from nature but it's to satisfy the the
natural needs that we have and then
artificial wealth
um and a lot of what what you know we
call financial instruments Aristotle
would say is just artificial wealth and
it's you know we always got to be kind
of careful with that sort of thing you
know I will mention
um before I get to Nicole's question
something that was kind of an
interesting project here in Milwaukee
and I'm not sure if it's still ongoing
but I used to know the person who owned
it it was called the black pages and it
was a list of black owned businesses
here in Milwaukee where we have some
very high racial inequities and we're
one of the most segregated land wise
large cities in the United States and
one one of the things that the person
who put together the black Pages noticed
was
um there there were lots of black owned
businesses
and they were not you know keeping the
money in the community there was like a
you know sort of large-scale extraction
going on over time
and the idea was try to keep the money
circulating Within These communities
then these communities become more
prosperous which is better for the
individuals living in those communities
and it it you know sort of like raises
levels across the board but you got to
do that in a deliberate way
uh
some sense now Nicole has a good
question here can you be prodigal if you
are a fundraiser or a connector of
people's funds that's a good question
um
can you be prodigal we could say like in
a fiduciary position where you're it's
not your money that you're handling it's
somebody else's
money and I I think you could say Yes
um
like you you waste the money on
um poorly researched projects and it
doesn't
um do what it's supposed to do or you
spend the money on the wrong things this
is where Charities sometimes get in
trouble right
there was a big scandal
I want to say about 20 years ago
where it was revealed that United Way
which is a big charity that distributes
to other Charities was using the
majority of the funds for paying for
their staff
all right and that's not the way it's
supposed to work with a charity the
money that you're giving should be
mostly going to helping people not just
to providing jobs for people who are
supposed to be helping people right and
so I I think yeah you could say that you
could be prodigal you could be stingy
you could be generous
it's kind of interesting because it's
sort of in between the level of like
just plain old generosity and the level
of magnificence so this is actually a
great question
um that's a that's a great example of
something that Aristotle himself does
not consider and I don't think there's a
lot of room
in his culture for considering that
but it's a it's a major issue and our
culture isn't it because we have all
these organizations and all these
Charities and corporations that that
could be
involved in that and that are where
money is being managed by somebody else
uh this is from Steve curious how the
passage of time can play a role for
example maybe a person was stingy and
spending on a party for his or her
friends but later in life these friends
turn out to be phony assuming not in
reaction to the stinginess so they might
have been the right people at one time
and the wrong people at another time
that's a yeah that's a great example
um
do we re-evaluate
our assessments of a person's actions
like this spending on a party or
dispositions
um what they do over time when we see
how people turn out
um or you know what if you give to
people who seem like they're
good prospects but they all turn out to
be
spending their money on gambling or
drugs or you know another great example
cryptocurrency uh scams that are being
advertised on TV when we watch football
games you know it used to be that it was
all online gambling stuff and then for a
while it was crypto you know and if
Marky Mark is is telling you to get into
crypto now you've probably missed the
opportunity you know
um so if you give money to people and
they spend it poorly is it are you no
longer generous because of what they did
that's an interesting question I think
Aristotle would say this is my guess you
have to evaluate on like what the person
giving
what they were thinking at the time and
whether they had done some as we call it
due diligence so that that's a great uh
Point uh